I had a Stevie's Creole cafe to chop it
up with Carlos Miller
Amanda field bomani Jones and Emanuel
hood if black Twitter was a club they'd
all have their own VIP sections what is
it about side sick side dude humor that
is so enticing nothing is funnier than a
bad idea man all right I need these
stories do not ever it'd positively they
tend to always end in ruin
black ones look Trump and we love comedy
and so any time that there's errors
there's only comedy I'm pretty sure I'll
get a side dude you didn't know that it
wasn't confirmed but you get a feeling
in your back I ain't never had no side
chicken ain't never gonna side to my to
my knowledge I dated rappers so the odds
of me being a side chick at some point
are very high why are jokes about five
six and side dudes more popular in the
black community than in other
communities our ability to always take
everything and turn it into positives is
something that black folks have been
forced to do and so it's just one of the
next things that we do what's she saying
is that black twitter's gumbo right and
the scraps are the things that maybe the
mainstream doesn't deal with like side
shaking rebellion thrown that in the
room and we overhear feet we know
something and we cook it I think it's
more taboo to white people because we
know white people get down wait like a
white do I have a side chick and plan to
kill his whole family so he can be with
blacks what is really about the side
yet now that are massaging this
kind of situation I think it's
misogynistic because it never ends up
being about the fact that you shouldn't
have a side chick in the first place the
side chick is practiced how am I gonna
know how to treat you and what nice
blazer to take you if I can't being a
relationship just freestyling Amanda my
girl Amanda likes seafood
me and my side chick need to come here
on a Thursday afternoon and see what
Steve is talking about I'm not about to
bring my baby to Stevie's in the humble
not the way she like it you listen to it
for sometimes you're on inside that's
what the sunglasses it's something like
a black Twitter pioneer so I made this
mean that's it I might not be the man
crush Monday but I smashed on
sad for Sunday you may talk about five
six Monday through Saturday but thanks
to Carlos sunday is the day to
appreciate the side to our these means
this humor normalizing adultery within
our generation of course but normalizes
it it ain't normalizing it is what has
been forever and ever
putting used to have shame attached to
it and now I got ya but Bill Clinton
almost got in peace but we knew how Bill
Clinton got down a long time before that
and we made him a president for women is
never been a look to be as I chase now
how does he winded you know he's also
when Kermit the Frog he's pretty much
the mayor of sidechick town that moment
you see an old slide chick and she is
walking with the kid let's talk about
Carmen Carmen Muppets he's not supposed
to be representing mashing bangs on the
side Kermit the Frog ass fat chicks he
drinking hand it to somebody
photoshopped a cigarette on fair play
and the places I played come to the Frog
mi hermanito
I relate I think it's also funny because
it just represents a loss of innocence
yeah it's like when your parents get
divorced so when you find out your
grandpa's cheese on your grandma once
and Kermit is here to be like hey yeah
innocence is over and real stuff is
happening that thing I want you guys to
give me some commitment humor means for
this picture right here when you find a
perfect neighborhood to raise your
family in aa with your wife because
you're faithful ah and you don't cheat
on her when you and your wife bought
your first home together oh damn that
aint funny
the next meme is Barack kissing Michelle
in front of an Easter Bunny I got one
when he went to carrot you failed only
thing that I can think of is like when
it's a threesome in you waiting on your
turn that's that's not all right
[Music]
so okay